I saw this report that just came out
mediaites most influential in news media
2022 and I'm curious to know who you
think ends up being in the top five so
if you can pull this I want to start off
with number 75 and go work our way down
okay uh just go okay so if you can right
there so Ben Smith 75 uh uh he's the
former CEO Bloomberg media Taylor uh
Lawrence in April uncovered a woman
behind the popular vehemently anti-lgbt
Libs of tick tock Twitter account wow
she makes top 75. and they got Ben
Collins Donnie Solomon which is NBC News
CNN Chris Christie got it Kate uh go uh
Boldin uh at 71st this is uh she had a
show with CNN plus and then it was done
with Twitter video influencers okay
they're putting that as a whole
everybody in one uh gamut then you got
Josh gerstein and Alexander Ward Jessica
tarloff from Fox News she's a co-host of
uh uh the five she's the Democrat and uh
you got it Oliver Oliver Darcy the
is next then you go to Benjamin Hall
then it's Andrew Ross Sorkin who is way
too low so it should be way up I agree
he's the guy he's the one that just
interviewed uh what do you call it do
you know read SPF just a week ago then
he got crazy smart very neutral and
what's he doing down there then he got
Dana Perino and Bill Hammer okay so they
were next that's again uh uh uh
America's Newsroom together on Fox from
9 to 11. Sarah Fisher uh from Mr Beast
and charity to Snapchat Trump Tick Tock
us moves Chris Wallace new okay that's
her then you have Nicole Wallace former
white house uh communication director
turned to MSNBC anchor uh Dylan Byers
his reporting on CNN and his parent
company Warner Brothers then he got clay
Travis from outkick then he got Laura
Coates and Allison camarota uh is next
and it's Ellie honig then it's Savannah
Guthrie Aaron Burnett then he got
Charles Barkley 55th having Inked a new
contract with TNT in October that could
pay him nearly 200 billion dollars wow
over 10 years Berkeley now gets paid
more money to talk about basketball than
all but a handful to play basketball by
the way he made more money being an
announcer than he was playing basketball
pretty wild when you think about that
yeah I'm happy for him Kevin Poole uh
when Keith Poole is 54th and it's Andy
Andy McCarthy new Fox legal analyst
and it got Alex Wagner uh then he got
Gail King makes sense then he got
Cecilia Vega
uh Chris Cromwell 49 still on the list
Martha is Cuomo still on this list yeah
by the way he would have been much
higher if this was when he was active
Martha McCollum Callum yeah then he got
Jim Acosta 47th and he got Jonathan
Swann John Swann is a beast Geraldo
Rivera still on the list Lawrence
O'Donnell uh Robin Roberts and Michael
Strahan interesting Jim Cramer still on
there lots of a lot of credibility this
year with what he said about FTX uh
Steve kornacky Chris Hayes Margaret
Brennan ABC's new Chief Kim Godwin and
CBS News co-president Niraj
and Wendy McMahon Choctaw 37 Joe Reed
Joy Reid is that high Joy Reed is that
much above pretty weird no she's on
there yeah [ __ ] you got Shimon uh Pro
kupex is 35th Harris Faulkner then he
got Ari melbner Bill Maher 32nd is a 30
that guy should be in the top ten I
think he's top 20 at least Ari Emmanuel
and Jay sures 31st Stephen A Smith 30th
makes sense nice uh Laura Ingram 29th
Chris Wallace 28 Rachel Maddow 27 Brett
Bear 26th Jonathan Carl 25th Anderson
Cooper 24 Charlemagne the guy 23. 23rd
that's good for him man 22nd Megan Kelly
still on the list 21st Cara uh Swisher
20 of Joe Rogan I thought for sure Joe
Rogan would have been higher than 20.
that was Joe Rogan not very well very
weird but he's on the 20th he gets more
ratings than CNN and fox combines
influential and we get to decide what
influences so 19 Peter Ducey 18th
Rashida Jones uh Caesar candy and Noah
oppenheim 17th is the few everybody on
The View so whoopee Joy Sunny Sarah
Alyssa and Anna then 16 you got Jesse
Waters 15 got Don Lemon Caitlyn and
Poppy okay CNN morning Fortuna got Steve
Ducey Ainsley Earhart that's Fox and
Friends let's Fox and Friends yeah then
he got George Stephanopoulos 13th Place
12 Jake Tapper 11 Ben Shapiro wow Ben
Shapiro number 11 says a lot about what
they're doing so 10th Greg gutfield
that's the one that's insane to be 10th
Place wow Greg gutfield okay that's top
10 by the way nine Maggie Haberman New
York Times correspondent and then you
got Lester Holt Nora O'Donnell and David
Muir that's from uh NBC's uh show and
then he got Matt drudge from Drudge
Report Tom it's interesting that he's
seventh by the way very intense Sean
Hannity sixth Joe Scarborough Mika and
Willie fifth Tucker fourth Chris Licht
and David zaslav CNN new CEO third Elon
musk's second wow Elon number two
you buy Twitter you just you're in right
absolutely you would never get first
place but first place is Suzanne Scott
rarely have we put someone at the top of
the list who isn't a media star known to
most of the country but considered a
strange hold that Fox News has held has
over the media industry and it's easy to
say why Suzanne's got to see Fox News is
the most influential person in all Media
Fox News will end 2020 T 2022 as the
most watched Network in all of cable
news in both daytime Prime Time viewers
for the seventh consecutive year in a
year where viewership is down across the
board Fox News remains a rating
Juggernaut its audience often bigger
than CNN and MSNBC combined wow so there
you go Suzanne Scott good for you
congratulations fast forward yeah 10
years how much different does this look
like this List look like meaning German
still at the top of the list are the
foxes the cnns the msnbcs
10 years from now how many are going to
be
podcasters independent journalists
people that are not typical Legacy
mainstream media what do you think pbd
it's going to be and where will you be
on this list sir dramatically different
of uh this list this list is changing
and they're they're also realizing they
have to change Joe being at 20th spot
fine but Joe's got to be much harder
than that Joe you kidding me in 2022
he's top 10 minimum two being the top
ten yeah but there's gonna be more names
to be on that list as well so what all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
or black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future look
spread toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]